morning everybody thank you for coming
in at 9 o'clock it's an early start
so as Kevin mentioned my name is Kirsty
Nathu and I'm the CFO here at Y
Combinator so I've actually helped now
2,000 companies almost as they've come
through Y Combinator so seen a lot seen
a lot of successes and seen a lot of
failures so I'm going to help you just
understand some of the big mistakes that
we see some of these companies doing
based on their cash based on their money
and so for every business whether it's a
start-up or a mom-and-pop shop
cash is its lifeblood and if you run out
of cash then the business dies there's
doesn't really no going back at that
point and it's actually surprisingly
easy to run out of cash and we see many
startups not realize that they they have
done that until it's too late to
actually be able to turn it around and
do something about it
so we're going to talk about these three
early-stage pitfalls so this is probably
most relevant to you right now and then
we'll talk through another three that as
you start to raise money and are
starting to think about hiring some
other other mistakes that companies make
so we're going to look at what the
numbers you should be looking at how
often you should be looking at them
whether your expenses are realistic and
then thinking a little bit more about
hiring and looking at responsibilities
alright so let's move on to the first
one um so the first mistake is really
not knowing what numbers to look at to
make sure that the health of your
company is is good and really there are
three things that you should know your
bank balance the money coming in and the
money going out and these are not
difficult you don't need anything fancy
to be able to do this this is all
information you can get from your online
banking or your bank statements you
don't need bookkeepers you don't need
financial software this is super
straightforward but you would be amazed
at how many companies don't look at this
and then using these three numbers you
can then calculate some other things you
can look at burn you can look at your
runway you can look at growth rate and
you can figure out whether the company
default alive okay let's go through
these in order your burn is purely money
in - money out again you can get this
from your bank statements it's
effectively just the change in bank
balance between two dates here's an
example super easy
you have 25 K expenses you have 10 K of
revenue so your burn is 15 K if your
expenses are a little bit lumpy some
companies you know you might have a
one-off month where where you I don't
know paid a legal bill or something
that's super high you can do this you
can look to average expenses as well to
figure out your burn and that's often
referred to as average burn so you might
look at this over three months to kind
of get it get more of an idea so then
once you know your burn then you can
start to look at what your runway is and
what this means is how long do you have
until you run out of money and the way
that you calculate that is you look at
your existing bank balance divide it by
your average burn and that gives you a
number of months so here we have 150 K
in the bank we've just calculated our
burn rate to be 15 K and so we have 10
months of runway again super
straightforward but you'd be amazed at
how many companies or how many founders
don't know these numbers for their
company and just a point here that again
the burn might change over time but this
is a number for you this is not a number
to try to make things look good this is
for you to not lie to yourself so
looking at the burn and going well this
month it was 15 K but let's just pretend
it was 10 K so then that makes it look
like that we have 15 months of runway
left all you're doing is lying to
yourself you're still going to run out
of money on the same day it's just
making you feel better right now so it's
super important to really be honest with
yourself on these you can also look at
your growth rate and so this is just
looking at two periods of
time so your money in a month to minus
you money in in month one divided by
your money in a month one so this is
looking at the the rate that your
revenue is increasing so in our example
here we have 10k of revenue in July 12 K
in August and so our growth rate is 20
percent and just a note for the for the
people that weren't the the math whiz
was as at school a constant growth rate
is what's going to give you the J curve
in growth of revenue because if you have
20% growing each month as your numbers
increase each month that 20% caesar is a
larger number okay and then the final
one is whether the company is default
alive or the other the other side of it
is is it default dead so the way you
calculate this is if your expenses are
constant and your revenue growth that
you've just calculated continues have
you got enough cash to reach
profitability and there's a handy little
calculator that Trevor Blackwell who's
one of the founders of Y Combinator
created for you to do this and basically
there are three things that you can you
can play with so you can look at your
monthly expenses which is the red line
you can look at your monthly revenue
starting point which is the green point
over at the start and then you can
change the gradient of that line to be
your growth rate and it will calculate
where you become profitable and how much
capital is needed now this example isn't
the same numbers as the ones that we've
just been working through so in this
example this is assuming that you will
need 150 K of money to get to
profitability and it will take you two
years and so those are really key things
to know because if you only have 100 K
of money in your bank account you know
that you've got a problem and you know
that you either need to find a way to
increase your revenue growth or you need
to find a way to cut expenses because
the whole goal here is to be at the
point where you can find a path to
profitability because it gives you
freedom being profitable gives you
freedom because you aren't in a position
to need to raise money and kind of like
dating if you don't need to raise money
you appear less desperate so your the
investors want to give you money more so
it's easier to raise money so it's
actually really important to have that
option it can sometimes you know it can
be it can be a switch as well you don't
have to necessarily be profitable right
now but if you know that you could turn
off one specific expense or do one
specific thing and be profitable then
that's also a great safety net there's
also a really great essay that talks
about this in more detail this was
written by Paul Graham and you can see
the the link here to where that that
gives you more information on this and
again is the kind of thing that when
we're doing office hours with founders
it's one of the first questions we ask
and you'd be amazed how many people
don't know the answer these numbers
super easy to calculate super
straightforward the next problem is that
people go along and they say ok I've
looked at my runway I've looked at my
revenue I know all my numbers and then
kind of forget about it but actually
this needs to happen pretty often you
shouldn't be looking at it every quarter
or every month you should be looking at
it at least every week and if your
runway is getting low or things are
looking not very constant consistent you
should be looking at it very often like
sometimes daily and whenever anyone asks
you should know your numbers have a have
a think now how many of you know how
much money is in the company bank
account if you already have one great
how much have you know your runway
slightly less number slightly less hands
but that's that's pretty good I like it
I'm impressed
okay the next one is under representing
your expenses so if you think back to
that default alive' calculator that
assumes that your expenses are going to
remain constant and actually in reality
that's probably unlikely most startups
their expenses will ramp up over time
and you should you should understand how
that's going to happen you know what
kind of expenses are going to increase
and what are they going to increase to
so some examples of
expenses that may change over time is
the first one is undervaluing your own
time particularly in the early days
where you're doing everything and you're
either paying yourself minimum wage or
some very small amount which by the way
in California or everybody should pay
themselves minimum wage and you're also
doing things that don't scale in order
to acquire users and that's totally fine
and that's what we recommend that people
do but it can make your customer
acquisition costs look lower than really
they are and so you should be aware that
over time as you start to hire people to
look into these that those expenses are
going to go up hiring people is not just
their salary for every person that you
hire you need to provide them with
equipment you need probably desk space
you need health insurance probably
depending on where you're based and so
all of these things cost extra money on
top of the salary and so depending on
location a good rule of thumb is that an
employee will cost about 25 to 50
percent more than just their salary so
if they're being paid 100k year then
your fully loaded cost to the company is
going to be somewhere between 125 K 250
K and again that's super easy to forget
about you think oh I'm going to hire an
engineer I'm gonna pay the 100 K that
means you know that's all it's going to
cost but it's it's amazing how those
numbers do add up so just be aware of
those finally assuming paid acquisition
costs remain constant is another another
mistake that we see people make a lot
whilst it may not seem like this often
times in the early days it's actually
easiest to find your early users because
they're the ones that are totally
motivated to use the product and
actually over time it gets harder to
find and convert users and so the cost
of doing that goes up and so again you
know you should be thinking about that
you should be looking at what your costs
are right now and seeing thinking are
they reasonable what do we think they
might go up to because if you can look
at things in the worst case scenario and
you have you know in the worst case
scenario you
callate that you have eight months of
revenue eight months of runway left but
actually then things are better than
that and you end up with ten months of
revenue then that's bonus right you've
got you've got a bit longer to figure
things out
runway is not a vanity metric it's not
one of these things that's supposed to
make you feel good is not one of the
things that's supposed to be used to
compare yourself against other companies
is for you to know the health of your
company and so don't ignore this stuff
don't lie to yourself don't you know try
to massage these numbers to feel like
it's making yourselves better because
all that's gonna happen is you're
running out of money and it'll become a
shock all right so these ones now are
starting to get a little bit more as you
raise money as you starting to hire
people so it's good to bear in mind
right now but these are probably less
relevant to a lot of you for now okay
the first one is outsourcing
responsibility and often the CEO will
hire a bookkeeper and to prepare the
finances for a company as they start to
get a little bit more complex and that's
a total normal thing to do we recommend
that people do that it's usually once
people raise some money it's not a good
time it's not a good use of the CEOs
time to be doing the books and the CEO
can be doing much more high leverage
things but the things about in mind is
that even though the bookkeeper is doing
the books and preparing those numbers
the responsibility is still everybody's
in the company particularly the CEO but
all the founders everybody should know
what these numbers are an external
bookkeeper isn't going to know the
business like you know the business you
know oftentimes they will the way that
they they work is that they will get
hold of bank statements and they'll see
money coming in and they'll see money
coming out and they'll do their best
guess about what these things are and
they won't always be right and you can't
really expect them to always be a
hundred percent right because they're
looking at it from a very removed
position and so it's up to the founders
and it's up to the team to look at those
reports that the bookkeepers send every
month and to make sure that you
understand them and to make sure that if
anything that comes through that looks
strange you question it's not
necessarily
think I think a lot of it is that people
are concerned that asking questions will
make it look like they don't understand
their numbers but usually what happens
is if you don't understand what these
numbers are looking like it's usually
because there's there's been some
misunderstanding in the reporting of the
numbers and so if you're like well I
thought my revenue was going to be a bit
higher this month for what's going on
why is why is this you know why is this
this number then you can actually go in
and look and query what's what's going
into that and you know you might find
that there has been a mistake made and
this is this is probably one of the
number one things that I get founders
coming to me complaining about they'll
come up to me in this total panic and be
like the bookkeeper messed up and they
told us all this wrong stuff and now I
don't know I have no runway and I don't
know what's going on and actually what
happened is the bookkeeper sent them the
monthly reports they were like tick done
my work founders didn't look at them the
report didn't figure out what was going
on and now there isn't enough time left
for them to turn the business round
either to get profitable or to raise
money to figure things out and the
company dies because it runs out of cash
so super super important to be on this
all the time hiring too quickly and
scaling the company too quickly is it's
really easy to do to hire too quickly
because you're under a lot of pressure
to to hire people it feels like it's a
it's a really easy really measurable
piece of information you know you talk
to founders and one of the first
questions that they will often ask is
also how many employees are you at right
now and you say alright you know I'm at
25 and you're thinking oh no I've only
got 10 employees that means that you
know way more successful than I am and
actually that's totally not true so we
already mentioned that hiring employees
cost more than just their salary but you
should also be conscious that every hire
is actually an investment into the
business and you should be making sure
that you're getting a return on that
investment and now for some types of
employees that's super easy to measure
so you know think about a salesperson
they're not bringing in more sales than
it's costing the business to hire them
then clearly you're not getting a good
return on investment but then think
about a community manager or a you know
as a support manager it is much harder
to measure that and that's kind of one
of the things that as a CEO you need to
be looking at and you need to be
figuring out to make sure that all the
people in your company are actually
working to make the company more
valuable and sadly this is the point
where you know if people aren't working
out you should be prepared to fire fast
you know if people aren't pulling their
weights then they need to they need to
leave the company and like I say it's
easy to fall into this trap that the
more people you have the better you
doing but actually the best companies do
more with less
and so actually the real way that you
should measure yourselves is what's my
ratio of revenue to employees because
the higher that is the better you doing
you're doing more with less
and that's the path to being profitable
from an early stage which then takes the
pressure off to the the worry about
whether the company is going to continue
and it's also easy to feel like you have
to kind of compete with with all the
flashy startups that have raised bunches
of money and they're all hiring data
scientists right now and you know oh
that means I must need a data scientist
so I'd better hire a data scientist
actually don't you know that the again
the best companies do more with less and
if you can if you can build a really
great company with less employees then
that's amazing for everybody involved
and bear in mind you know you should be
treating this money carefully it's not a
case of just oh I need to hire this
person I need to hire that person
because what the investors who are
giving you this money for they're asking
you to do something basically a miracle
they're asking you to take their money
and turn it into ten or a hundred times
that amount of money to give back to
them and the way you're going to do that
is by being careful with your expenses
and making sure that your revenue grows
as a follow-on to that scaling before
you get product market fit is also
another dangerous thing that people fall
into quite easily
at the point where he's still figuring
out what your product is and you're
trying to find product market fit you
should be spending as little as possible
and then that will give you the runway
to have time to figure out what it is
that you you should be building and then
you know people will be beating down the
door to buy your product more employees
will not help you get to product market
fit it will not help you get there
faster it will not help you get there
more efficiently and one of the
conversations that I have with founders
is something along the lines of oh my
sales are low because I don't really
have enough sales people so if I hire
another couple of salespeople they're
marseilles will obviously increase that
doesn't sound like product market fit to
me you know if it if you have that then
customers are beating a path to your
door and you know it it feels like the
wheels are trying to wheels are falling
off as you're trying to look after all
those customers so just hiring more
salespeople isn't necessarily going to
be the thing that sets that going also
convincing yourself that you need more
developers or you need more people to to
get the thing that gives you the the
product market fit another conversation
along this is something like I need for
more developers because then I can build
feature x y&z and then obviously
everybody will buy it but again if you
have product market fit then even your
junk ev0 that doesn't have all of these
fancy things is solving a big enough
problem for everybody that they're
willing to pay for it and they love you
for it anyway and then you can start
building up on the more features and
then you can start hiring to do that
this is this is the one that there's no
coming back from the other ones if you
make these mistakes you can you can
probably solve this Sonique and you know
if you hide too quickly you can figure
that out if you don't know your I spent
I don't know your numbers you can learn
your numbers this is the one that is you
know no going back so if you let your
runway get too low before raising you're
going to have problems raising your
money so the first thing is you should
always assume that you will never raise
any more money always assume that the
previous
money that you raise will be your last
and that you should be aiming to get to
profitability on that money so again the
conversations that I have with founders
where they say oh it's fine my investors
are gonna put in another million dollars
it'll be totally fine that's kind of
scary if you're relying on your
investors to do that because they don't
always sometimes they might but they
don't always so Steve's stage money is
the money that you'll raise off and on
just an idea you know you'll be able to
talk to investors about a an idea for a
product you've got a hypothesis that you
you want to be able to check and they
will give you some money once you get to
series a and beyond that becomes much
much harder you know you need sustained
growth you need to have more of an idea
you need to have product market fit this
is why it's a lot harder to raise money
as you go through the life of the
company and in particular don't leave it
too late because if you're running out
of runway your leverage goes down as
you're trying to raise money so if you
have six months of runway let's say and
you think you're about to go and start
raising money that's pretty scary it
could take three months more to actually
get an investor to agree to put money in
and as your cash balances are decreasing
over those three months you know you're
losing leverage you can see from here
that probably at six months you maybe
you can just about pull it off but
really you want to be thinking about 12
months runway that's the point where
you're thinking okay maybe I need to
think about whether I raise money or
whether I'm thinking about getting to
profitability and also if you get to six
months and you're unsuccessful in
raising money you really don't have a
lot of time to turn this around to get
to profitability for the company to
succeed again there's a really great
essay on our blog that goes into this in
more detail linked down here so you can
you can read that at your at your
leisure
and hopefully take that on board okay so
in conclusion
most companies die because they run out
of money it's super easy not to run out
of money just by looking at
number of things knowing your cash
balance in your runway understanding how
your expenses are going to increase
understanding that the ratio of revenue
to employees is a better metric than
just the number of employees and having
a plan to get to profitability because
you should assume you're not going to
raise any more money all right thank you
very much okay so a few minutes for
questions so the question is how do you
how do you balance the the two sides of
you should do things on a shoestring and
be profitable as early as possible
versus you should just throw money and
get market share as fast as possible I
know I think it depends on the stage of
the company as well you know in the
early days then probably being careful
with your money and making sure that you
are you have a plan to get to
profitability is a good thing just
having a plan doesn't mean that you
necessarily have to actually be doing it
you know so so an example might be maybe
you're plowing all of your revenues back
into marketing in some description or
rather and knowing that you could
actually slow you you you know the way
to the way to reduce your expenses is to
reduce your marketing which might slow
your revenue a little bit but it would
conserve that cash to preserve the
runway it's just it's a balancing act
and you know I mean the other thing you
have to bear in mind is that obviously
the investors want you to spend money
super fast they want you to come back to
them cap in hand with you know please
please give us more money so there is
that there are some tensions there but
it's all
just being responsible with it and
giving yourself enough time and enough
runway to be able to to figure it out
and I'm just curious at what stage do
you see a four-on-four engulfed in that
company do you start with the quiet exit
CFO first then I can probably see a bow
falls out okay so the question is when
do you bring in a CFO it's surprisingly
late actually even probably post series
a you probably don't need a full-time
CFO at that point and there's a lot of
services that do you know consulting
CFOs and and will do will do sort of
strategy or you know help you to figure
out your numbers to raise to create a
deck or whatever for raising money a
full-time CFO is actually pretty late on
just to bear in mind that the difference
between a CFO and a bookkeeper at least
for the for the u.s. is that generally
the way that this works is the
bookkeeper you would you would have
earlier and they're they're the people
who are just going to get your your
numbers that are coming through your
bank statements into a balance sheet
into an income statement into the
accounting system so they're providing
the reports for that and then separately
to that you would hire a CPA an
accountant who would prepare the tax
returns and file those for you each year
so there's actually two different sets
of people so a bookkeeper you would need
earlier a CPA you need annually to do
your tax returns and then a CFO who's
going to sort of oversee that and do
more of the building our forecasts
building out budgets and things like
that are probably a little bit later on
as well before that it's really the
founders they should be doing it
so so why can you have any calculate it
I mean there are tools online personally
I think it's actually better to build it
yourself because I I think it makes you
think about it in your mind and so
usually just doing good old spreadsheets
for me works well but certainly that
there are other ways that you can you
can do it and there's there's a lot of
services and and a lot of startups we
see a lot of startups applying to us
trying to help to make it easier to see
forecasts and things okay maybe one more
question and then we'll move on you have
a product market fit
Oh for investors so are you raising seed
stage money yeah okay so at the seed
stage so the question is should you
provide forecasts in your deck if you
haven't reached a product market fit and
the answer is probably no certainly the
seed stage if you're talking to
professional investors or experienced
investors they probably aren't really
going to look or ask you for that number
they'll they'll ask you for things like
so how could how big could this get and
what's the total market size and you
know questions like that but they're not
going to be looking for here's our
monthly growth predictions probably if
you're being asked those kind of
questions from investors and you're
raising money at the seed stage it
probably means that those investors and
not actually that's experienced at
investing in early-stage companies so
that's a data point for you to decide
whether it's it's a good person to to
work with certainly by the time you get
to series a however you should have you
should have some plans but you know the
point of a Series A is that you've got
product market fit and that you know you
know you have more of an idea I mean
forecasts are always forecasts you don't
know for sure but yeah okay I think we
are up so thank you very much I'm doing
an AMA on Friday so if there's questions
didn't get to then feel free to drop
them in there and I will answer as many
as possible of those thank you
[Applause]
you